is Toyota making a deadly Mistake by
refusing to produce only electric
vehicles actually Toyota's CEO Akio
Toyota thinks other automakers secretly
feel the same way he does in December he
told reporters people involved in the
Auto industry are largely a silent
majority that silent majority is
wondering whether EVS are really okay to
have as a single option
but they think it's the trend so they
can't speak out loudly the actions of
his Rivals speak differently they're
embracing the electric revolution in
fact they've given themselves deadlines
at which point their companies will only
produce electric vehicles Honda plans to
ditch gas-powered cars by 2040. General
Motors by 2035. Volvo by 2030. Toyota
aims to sell three and a half million
EVS annually by 2030 but that only
accounts for one-third of the total
Vehicles they sold in 2021. a Kia Toyota
has described this company as a
department store offering a range of
products EVS are just one option
alongside gasoline driven cars
hydrogen-powered cars and hybrids and
plug-in hybrids Toyota's CEO believes
today's infrastructure cannot handle all
cars becoming fully electric he warned a
couple of years ago that if Japan banned
the sale of gas-powered cars and they
all had to run on electric power Japan
would run out of electricity in the
summer when people use more electricity
to air condition their homes
but is his alarmist attitude warranted
even if a country bans sales of new
gas-powered Vehicles which many are
planning to do it doesn't mean all
vehicles will become electric overnight
it will take years before every
gas-powered car is off the road if you
take the example of Germany the
consulting firm McKinsey found in their
2018 study that by 2050 the number of
EVS on the road in that country will
grow to 40 percent but that would only
add four percent or about 20 gigawatts
of additional energy capacity
it gets more complicated if people
decide to charge at the same time like
after they return home from work in an
area with a higher concentration of EVS
such as cities and suburbs Mackenzie
warns unmanaged EV charging power demand
will eventually push local Transformers
beyond their capacity requiring upgrades
McKinsey found implementing time of use
rates in which electricity is cheaper at
certain times of the day could have
demand during Peak periods storing
energy through a unit like a Tesla
powerwall can also reduce the stress on
the system during busy times
Tesla driver is charging at certain
sites in high demand have had their
battery charge limit set to 80 percent
so they don't take up a stall longer
than necessary charging speeds slow down
the closer you get to a full battery but
this is more to avoid overcrowding than
to decrease energy demand Akio Toyota's
comments also assume that the electrical
grid won't change he said upgrading
Japan's grid would cost hundreds of
billions of dollars despite the cost
many believe it will be necessary
although the grid might look a lot
different from what it is today
Julie Goodman of LF energy a project of
the non-profit Linux Foundation believes
the grid of the future isn't going to be
a grid at all it will be more like the
internet with power generation happening
all over the place something like a
forest she said to The Washington Post
could waffling on EVS now hurt Toyota
later
ironically Toyota used to be the leader
in clean cars it wowed the world with
the Prius in 1997 a hybrid hybrids
combine batteries with gas engines so
they use less fuel than traditional gas
cars then it seemed Toyota was making
the shift to fully electric vehicles it
came out with the RAV4 EV the same year
it was available on a limited basis and
Toyota sold around 300 units
it partnered with Tesla to produce a
second generation all-electric RAV4 but
that was discontinued after two years it
was only available in California and
there were issues with long charging
times Tesla and Toyota then went down
different paths Tesla pushed forward
with selling only fully electric
vehicles and is now on track to build 2
million cars a year while Toyota stuck
with their trusty hybrids the success of
the hybrid helped Toyota become what it
is today one of the world's largest
automakers sales of hybrids continue to
be strong despite an industry-wide
Slowdown Toyota sold two and a half
million hybrids globally in 2021 but how
long will their popularity last
while hybrids were first on the market
EVS have exploded quickly in popularity
in recent years according to statistics
from the U.S Department of
Transportation yet Toyota hasn't been
very successful in selling EVS it only
managed to sell around 200 units of its
fully electric model this year the bz-4x
and then it had to Halt production
reportedly over concerns that the wheels
could detach from the vehicle the bz-4x
is Toyota's only fully electric vehicle
so far despite promising to introduce 30
all-electric models by 2030. Will Toyota
change its strategy and embrace a fully
electric future Akio Toyota remains
committed to offering a range of
vehicles proclaiming that's our strategy
and we're sticking to it
he wants to make sure he doesn't lose
customers by limiting options saying we
don't want to leave anyone behind
by adopting this risky strategy will
Toyota leave itself behind as other
automakers race toward a fully electric
future
it remains to be seen whether Toyota can
protect itself from the competition It's
always important to protect yourself
when you're online that's why I trust
surfsharkvpn a VPN keeps you safe by
covering up everything you do online all
your information is in a way blurred out
or encrypted anyone who tries to Snoop
on you won't be able to see what you're
doing or where you're located it was
thanks to a VPN that I was able to buy a
bottle of Tesla tequila before it's sold
out you could only purchase it in the US
and at the time I was living in London
so I used a VPN to switch locations make
the purchase and eventually I picked it
up from the states a VPN also lets you
watch new movies and TV shows that
aren't usually available in your country
it's also great if you're traveling and
want to watch your usual streaming
services from home if you use my custom
link in the description to sign up for
surfsharkvpn you'll get 85 off plus an
extra three months for free all you have
to do is enter the promo code newsthink
for 85 off your subscription and three
extra months for free
thanks for watching for a news think I'm
Cindy Palm